the beauty of a marketplace is that I
get to choose my values I get to pursue
my values I get to use my mind to figure
out what my values are there's no way
for central planner there's no way for
somebody else to pick values for
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro shows Sunday special I'm really
eager and excited to welcome to the show
Yaron Brook Jeroen is the head of the
Iran Institute and also the host of the
Yaron Brook podcast the armed Brook show
so Yaron thanks so much for stopping by
I really appreciate my pleasure I'm glad
we finally got got hooked up I got
something objective is in the crowd have
been pressuring me for literally years
to have young and I kept saying like I
have no objection to talking to
Objectivist in fact I have a lot of
sympathies with objections so let's
let's just jump right in so when we
start from kind of your personal history
how did you become an Objectivist how
did you get into this so when I was 16 I
grew up in Israel so when I was 16 I was
I was in Israel living in Israel and as
most Israelis of my generation I was a
collectivist a tribalist you know I was
waiting for the grenade to say I could
jump on the grenade for therefore the
Jewish cause and then I was a socialist
as I think everybody in my generation
growing up this is before begging that
ever won an election the Socialists had
won every election and I'm I'm having
conversation with a friend and he said
he starts spouting these kind of
capitalist ideas and I go we getting
this nonsense from and he takes out a
book and he hands me Atlas Shrugged and
I read Atlas Shrugged then it took me
months to read Atlas Shrugged cuz I
fought it I did not want to believe what
he was saying I did not want to believe
this was true
she challenged pretty much everything I
believed in and by the book
she had won and I was it was hooked and
from there I picked up every single book
I could in Israel it was hard in those
days of some internet there was no way
to connect to anybody else who who had
these ideas so picked up every book I
could read everything and it really
spent the last 40 years studying her
ideas so instead of me trying to sum up
what I think objectivism is I have the
expert here so I don't use sort of
nutshell for folks who may not know what
objectivism is which is a fancy name for
a sort of Iran's philosophy yes what
exactly is objectivism sure so it's a
it's a philosophy based on the principle
that existence exists things are what
they are very Aristotelian a is a the
law of identity love cousin Eddie some
made up there's no creator that that you
know regulates the existence it just is
what it is and we as human beings have
the tools right to know reality and that
tool is reason we don't know about
reality through our emotions we don't
know through a revelation
we know reality through a reasoning
capacity and of course who reasons or
only individuals could reason there's no
collective consciousness any more than
there's a collective stomach you can't
eat from me you can't think for me so we
have to think for ourselves and what is
that what is it then the purpose of life
the purpose of life is to live for
yourself to live the best life you can
and make the most of your own life to
live a happy life in the end not
sacrificing to other people your values
and not asking other people to sacrifice
to you but to rationally live the best
life you can for yourself and what is
the only political system that leaves
you free to make decisions about the
rational values that you seek to pursue
in pursuit of your happiness well the
only system that leaves you free to do
that is capitalism the system that
protects our individual rights our right
to act freely so existence exists reason
as a means of survival egoism as a
morality and capitalism is the only
social political system that allows
egoistic people really to Sebago is to
go out and pursue their values so in a
second I wanna ask you about the areas
where we agree which is largely in the
free market area I think that Iran's
description of the markets and her
description of how capitalism works in
the creative impulse that is inherent in
most human beings I think that is
actually quite beautiful and I want to
ask you to expound on that in just a
second sure at first these days a lot of
workplaces offer employees some pretty
nice perks here at the Daily wire we
have a kitchen we have all sorts of
snacks also sometimes we even let our
employees go home and then we are just
full of perks that way one of those
perks that some companies is even life
insurance but you don't want to rely on
workplace life insurance this is where
policy genius comes in policy genius is
the easy way to shop for life insurance
online in minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find the right
amount of coverage at the best possible
price the policy genius team can look at
your workplace life insurance policy and
then help you decide what else you might
need
and what you don't policy genius doesn't
just do life insurance they also help
you find the right home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance
so remember workplace life insurance
policies kind of like workplace snacks
better than nothing not quite good
enough head on over to policy genius
today find out how to supplement your
workplace life insurance and better
protect your family policy genius it's
like a buffet made of life insurance
what could be more delicious than that
also guys just be an adult go get some
life insurance for yourself a fact is if
you leave your family bereft and poor
that's gonna be on you so why don't you
just go be a responsible human being I
know we're talking about selfishness and
self-interest it's in your self-interest
to provide for your family
because you care about them don't you I
mean there's still your family policy
genius gum okay so let's talk about the
free-market philosophy because when
people think of Iran particularly in
American politics they tend to think
specifically in the economic context
they think okay greed is good Gordon
Gekko selfishness is a virtue and they
think that that is a villainous conceit
they're basically the only way that that
we can live in a society together is not
to be selfish and particularly they hold
this is true in the in the realm of
economics you make the counter case you
say selfishness is really the only value
in economics that's going to forward
yourself and also afford the society at
large well what's the case for
selfishness well the case of selfishness
is that you only have one life and you
you know you you have a fundamental
choice that you have to live or not to
live right and that every choice should
be made around living that this
fundamental alternative shapes your
values all your values should be geared
towards your survival and survival as a
human being which means survival as a
full human with it with your rational
capacity your spiritual capacity your
capacity to you know live a complete and
full life so the argument for
self-interest in a broader sense is the
argument that basically says you you
know it's your life it's nobody else's
life it's your life live it for your own
sake live it to achieve your own
personal happiness and I believe one of
the challenges with capitalism is that
too many people over you know really
since out of Smith including Adam Smith
have tried to justify capitalism not
from an egoistic perspective not from a
selfish perspective now from the
perspective of individuals pursuing
their own happiness individual pursuing
their own values their own rational
values but from the perspective of what
it does for society so Adam Smith says
the Baker doesn't make the bread for you
he bakes the bread
for himself he's being selfish but we
don't like selfishness Adam Smith says
you know it's not a it's not a virtue
it's really deep down a vice but when
you add up all the vices it turns into a
virtue society is better off if
everybody pursues their self-interest
and I'm like oh nobody believes that if
you add up vices it turns into a into a
virtue I'm saying the Baker taking care
of himself and his family and feeding
them and in making a profit myself
that's virtue right and that's the malla
justification for capitalism you can't
justify capitalism from the perspective
of now the being Gordon Gekko is they're
really greedy but it turns out that if
they do that yeah the world's a better
place so we'll let them do it nobody
believes you and nobody's gonna allow
that to happen the regulatory state is
built around the idea that those greedy
selfish businessmen are going out cheat
they're gonna steal they're all crooks
because that's what we associate with
self-interest and therefore we have to
regulate them and control them now this
is where I got in trouble with some of
the Objectivist when I wasn't a Rubens
just talking about capitalism and one of
the things I suggested as I said that it
effectively has the same consequence as
forced altruism if that actually worked
you can't force altruism from other
people because then it loses the actual
character of altruism but more than that
what I was trying to say is that free
exchange is I don't get what I want from
you unless I give you something that you
want so the effect is that you get what
you want from me but that's only because
I'm also getting what I want from you so
the effect is the same I think the
linguistic kind of approach is different
I think the effect is completely
different
if the effect is completely different
because as you said you can't actually
do that through altruism very clear what
else Rosa means because there's a lot of
confusion about altruism altruism is a
term coined by Augustine compt the the
French philosopher in the nineteenth
century it's people use it today to mean
being nice and friendly and opening
doors though you know and say standing
up when an old woman you know gets on
the bus that's not altruist and that's
just being nice and being a kind of a
decent human being
altruism means living for others it
means never thinking of self denouncing
self being self less sacrificing your
own values for the sake of other
people's values now that to me is evil
right why is somebody else's life more
important than mine
somebody else's happiness more important
than mine to me the idea of sacrificing
my values sacrificing what is gonna
further my life for the sake of somebody
else that is wrong right
so altruism as a as a philosophical
concept in my view is is an evil concept
is a is a omalo concept that does not
negate being nice to people opening
doors and all of that stuff it doesn't
even negate helping people but any gate
sacrificing my values for the sake of
other people right so so forced ultras
and what is forced altruism even mean it
means I'm gonna force you to help other
people to give them what well as soon as
forces involved values are kind of out
the door because I'm not choosing as
soon as the central planning is involved
we don't know what's good for you what's
good for the other person the beauty of
our marketplace is that I get to choose
my values I get to pursue my values I
get to use my mind to figure out what my
values are them my values I'd be wrong
about them some of them might be might
be bad values but in the end of the day
I get to choose those values there's no
way for central planner there's no way
for somebody else to pick values for me
well obviously I agree with all of that
so I think that the the question becomes
is there a secondary value that is not
being acknowledged when we talk about
selfishness and I think that you know
most people agree that when you're
talking about selfishness obviously
you're talking about selfishness plus a
non-aggression principle meaning that
there are going to be many cases in
which my selfish interest would require
me to violate the rights of others I
mean this is what massive government
does on a routine basis so I would argue
that that's not true the government does
not excel facially government acts you
know in the in the in the counter
against the interests of the people in
government side
I don't think politicians are being
selfish when they try to when they try
to gain more power right let me be more
specific so you have three people in a
room two of them vote to take the third
guy's wealth yes that is that is a
self-interested move by the two people
voting to take the third guys wealth so
no I don't believe that so I don't
believe it's self-interested this is the
problem and the way we think about
self-interest right so we've been
conditioned to think about the world in
terms of to what model system one anti
mall system and the one mall system
means be selfless take care of others
focus all your efforts on others this is
the altruist
system and the second system is do
whatever whatever takes to get whatever
you need whatever you know that in a
lying cheating stick is stealing
backstabbing that's self-interest but
neither one of those that this is not
the alternative to altruism that we
alternate to altruism is to be a
rational value seeker and as a rational
value seeker
I don't want your stuff your stuff has
no value to me I want it on my stuff if
I don't earn my stuff I don't get any
self-esteem from earning that stuff the
money in and of itself is meaningless
the meaning money has is a reward for
doing something productive for creating
something for building something from
making something so I am never I never
perceive the idea of I'm gonna vote to
take somebody else's stuff no hey you
know first that concedes the idea that
force is okay that concedes the idea
that there's no such thing as rights and
they're gonna come after me next right
so just on a pragmatic sense that's bad
but for self for a spiritual sense from
a self self-esteem perspective I don't
want to light cheat and steal in order
to get stuff that's bad for me that's
not self-interested in my view that's
actually being selfless because it's not
thinking about what's truly good for me
if I think what's truly good for me it's
to be productive it's to be rational
it's to earn what I get it's to consume
only what I produce in a sense of I I
agree with your your analysis of what
would be the proper move in in terms of
what my self-interest is but I guess the
question is that it's difficult to suss
out from the language that is often used
in the world of Objectivism when I when
people hear selfishness what they hear
is self-interest yes and self-interest
is something I can't decide for you but
you are actually deciding for me what my
self-interest is when you're talking
about this either saying that I can
improperly act on my own self-interest
which is not me being able to act on my
own perception of my self-interest
correct yes I believe they're universal
values their universal values that
relate to self-interest right its
self-interest requires certain values to
be pursued I believe you know the three
cardinal values that I knew and
identified a reason purpose and
self-esteem every human being in order
to be happy in order to be successful
at living you know what they have a
successful life has to pursue reason has
to pursue a purpose in his life and has
to pursue his own self-esteem those are
the values that you need and then she
actually articulates seven virtues
virtues that correspond to those values
and unnecessary actions that one needs
to take in order to achieve happiness so
people confuse and again this is I think
how altruism conditions us because
altruism has been around
certainly since Christianity altruism is
very much ingrained in Christianity it's
the essence it's it's just it's a
fundamental moral system in Christianity
I think Judaism is a little bit more
ambiguous but in terms of Christianity
there's no question altruism conditions
it's the thing in a certain way the hero
virtues that say in order to achieve
happiness every human being must follow
these virtues and how do we know these
virtues we don't know them through
Revelation obviously we don't know them
because they just exist out there and we
discover them out there in the world we
know them by empirical evidence what
leads human beings to success the people
who lie constantly do they actually
achieve happiness do they actually
achieve flourishing achieve prosperity
and answers no not if you understand
what to human happiness is that people
who are leeches people who live off of
others people who never produce anything
can they truly be happy no not if you
really examine history and you examine
the world around us so this is
interesting because I want to ask you
about the distinction in making
consequentialist arguments with regard
to free markets generally and the
consequentialist argument you're
actually making right now with regard to
selfish values it sounds like there's a
consequentialist argument being made on
behalf of the values of selfishness
meaning we know what will benefit you
and we know what won't benefit you
because we've seen this repeated we've
seen this experiment repeated many many
times we know what works and what
doesn't there's a sudden sense in which
this whole consequentialist if you
there's a false dichotomy here the way I
think human knowledge works is we start
by observing the world we start by
seeing instances of things occurring we
then generalize from that we generalize
we come up with a theory about what it
is and then we test it out into reality
when when you're coming up with morality
and this is where I think you can do I
Ottoman is when the the the the house
should we live how should a human being
live well what is life require well we
look at the world we say well half
people lived how is human progress being
achieved how an individual's being
successful well I think the first thing
you observe is people are successful and
suddenly the way humanity is progressed
is when reason is being applied to the
problem of human survival everything we
have around us that wonderful technology
around us right now the food we have you
know you can't even hunt without using
this without using you reason so reason
has to be the central value in order for
human beings to survive how do I know
this by looking around by inducing from
what's actually happened in reality what
actually happens everyday around it so
yes the the Objectivist principles are
induced from reality and then they
become principles and now once I figured
out that for example honesty is a good
strategy right that that you know lying
to myself is the worst bit and like the
others as bad I don't have to then every
time I'm facing a new situation thing
huh should I or shouldn't I
is it it might quote self-interest to
lie this time right no I've already
figured out there's a principle it's not
in my self-interest to be dishonest so
I'm not dishonest so these and these
principles are universal it's a very
natural law perspective and what you're
talking about is very close to the idea
of natural law right that we can discern
from the from the world around us what
are the rules by which we ought to live
yes and I would add to that human nature
right so it's not a I'm not finding it
in the world out there I'm finding an
interaction between the world out there
and and human life and what human life
requires and what my consciousness
requires as a as a conscious being so
one of the divisions that you and I have
is obviously a division over the
presence of God in the universe or the
necessity of a God based system for
philosophy and one of the things that
Rand obviously focuses tremendously on
is the notion that you are a free actor
you have free will you have the capacity
to reason and the scientific
materialists suggest precisely the
opposite right they suggest that
basically we are a ball of neurons
wandering there was a universe firing
without our permission and we don't have
the capacity to act freely in the
universe so in the religious view the
idea
freewill the idea of even reason is
discern from the notion that there is a
creator that the Creator has endowed you
with the capacity to reason and so that
is it fundamental assumption that's made
at the root of judeo-christian religion
where do you make the assumption that
reason is more than just a firing of
evolutionarily beneficial neurons and
that free will is is something that is
real or capable mean there are folks
like sam harris who argue nada
yes that I would disagree dramatically
with with Sam Harris on this I think you
get it through introspection I think
introspection is as valid as looking out
into the world and using your senses I
can observe the processes of my
consciousness I can observe them I can
see them and I can I can actually
observe me making choices and I think
there's you know I there's a certain
sense in which I agree with Sam house
raising your hand and waving your hand
of course yeah that's nuanced filing or
whatever I mean that's that's kind of
silly the the fundamental choice that we
all make is a fundamental choice that I
think those of us who make it absorb
make a positive choice observe it and
that is the fundamental choice to focus
on Minds uh you know you can drift in
life you can stay kind of kind of
without really putting everything in
focus and using your mind and activating
reason and this is one of the the funny
things I find with these materialistic
you know where do they get reason from
if there's no choice say there has to be
choice enough for a reason to mean
anything yep
where do they get choices and Sam house
talks a lot about choices and and any
talks of a morality right where is their
morality and choice without free will so
freewill to me as an action Matic
concept that is that is derive from a
direct observation it's just like a
Cartesian argument it's just well yes I
think therefore I am effectively well
but no because I don't think therefore
ham I am therefore I think but you know
so reason is an attribute of my
existence right my ability so freewill
is an attribute of the particular kind
of consciousness that human beings have
can I explain it scientifically no but
there are lots of things in the world we
can't explain scientifically and and we
also know that science advances and over
time we can explain more and more so why
draw a line at some point and say
because we can't explain it
scientifically right now it doesn't
exist but that's ridiculous I can act
see it right so it would be the
equivalent of I don't see the world is
wrong so it can't be round but we've got
but you know other people can actually
show that the world is wrong scientist
Galileo whatever control that the world
is round before get a little actually
right so so but we ignore that right so
I can actually observe I'm not gonna
negate my actual observation my actual
observation is the starting point for
everything in objectivism so existence
exist it's there I can see I can observe
it so you know in that sense you know
free will as an axiomatic concept you
start with that so are the rules of the
road culturally derived over over the
course of history do they evolve or
would a pure intellect Pure Reason be
able to discern the sort of
self-interested rules by which we ought
to live I think I think the rules of the
road the you know philosophers figure
this out I think it's hard I don't think
it's easy
Aristotle took a stab at it right what's
what's the goal of Aristotle's ethics
it's to live the good life right it's
it's to be it's to be an ego straight
it's to be selfish it's to live the best
life you can for yourself right and then
he tries to figure out what that look
what that looks like and I disagree with
him all that looks like but I agree with
the goal right so so I think that it
takes time to observe human behavior to
observe history evolving in order to be
able to figure out what the principles
are fix and I give an example a man said
that she could not have fully
articulated her moral code without
having lived post-industrial revolution
because she said the Industrial illusion
taught us something very very powerful
it taught us the existential value of
human reason because it's really the
first time on a massive scale that we
applied human reason to the problem of
human survival and achieve massive
amazing results
we took science we applied engineering
we added business and we got you know a
massive increase in wealth massive
increase in life expectancy and human
wellbeing dramatic but that is on every
stage it's the ad it's the application
of reason to this particular issue and
she said pre-industrial evolution that
wasn't obvious it's not clear because
you know as we've all seen the graphs
were for a hundred thousand
we basically lived at the same possibly
a subsistence level and so the UNESCO
village had taught us something and I'm
sure in the future we'll learn more
things about about life and about
reality out there that might change the
particular the particular orientation of
what it means to be self-interested
selfish but as of now as of the state of
knowledge we have as human beings right
now
I think Rand got it right so I want to
ask you a couple more questions about
reason one from the left and once order
from the right so the question from the
left is whether you're putting too much
faith in the ability of human beings to
reason right there's be the sort of
David Hume argument that in essence
reason is the is the reason is the right
around the elephant sort of as Jonathan
Hyde puts it right that emotion really
drives most of our decision-making that
at best you can slightly guide that but
for the most part the emphasis on reason
is a backfill of what we want to do
instinctively and this is obviously that
there are gradations of reason to so
you're operating maybe from a premise of
sort of the homo economist the the
perfect human who has the capacity for
reason and most people don't actually
make decisions like that in fact there
plenty of people who make decisions that
are very much against their own
self-interest and against their own
reason so how much can we rely on reason
as a tool in how most people live their
lives maybe you can maybe your
reasonable maybe I'm reasonable for a
vast society how much can we rely on
unreason well I think I think you have
to you have to differentiate between
descriptive and prescriptive right if
why describing the world yes a lot of
people don't live by reason most people
most of time unfortunately don't live by
reason but that's that they're not
living up to their full potential of
human beings and nobody's teaching them
to do it
nobody is encouraging them to do it
nobody is arguing that they should do it
there was a brief period in human
history the Enlightenment where people
actually talked about living by reason
and using reason to make important it
make decisions in your life and reason
is the source of knowledge and even they
weren't 100% consistent and didn't have
the full theory down to be able to do it
right so it's it doesn't happen
automatically reason is something you
have to choose reason is something you
have to pursue reason is something you
have to engage with it requires effort
it requires real work it doesn't just
come so again this is the counter to sam
house when
automatons we have to choose reason and
we live in a world and I think
ever-increasing where people are not
choosing till they're by reason and I
think that's a lot a big part of the
problems we have in the world I think
that most the problems we have in the
world world is is people evading the
choice to reason ignoring it and and and
not doing and therefore they're not
happy and the world is it's got all the
cultural and political problems that we
experience so I think everybody's
capable of reason and I think you see
that for example when you go into a lot
of a lot of workplaces you know Silicon
Valley is a good example you see people
incredibly engaged in logic and reason
and applying themselves to a particular
problem that they're facing and they're
brilliant at the amazing it but when
they leave work that switch is turned
off often so they have silly politics
not even you know just stupid politics
they might they might have personal
relationships that are really messed up
and not based on reason but based on
emotion but they you know they're
capable of it you because you could see
them doing it work and I'd say Americans
typically a really good at applying the
reason in a productive in their
productive endeavors and they're very
and and then they leave that at work and
they and they become different in a
sense different people outside of work
I'm saying if we educate people right if
we encourage them and we change them all
code we're telling them morality is
about reason if you want to be a good
person you should use reason so morality
is not about all the things that you've
been taught to be about being selfless
sacrifice living for the people all of
that Molly's reason really about living
the best life for yourself and to do
that you have to reason then I think
every human being is capable of it
whether every human being chooses to do
it as a different story but but every
model system that people who choose not
to follow it you know I argue that this
is the best model system for human
beings for individual human beings and I
would encourage them all to apply the
reason everybody has that capacity and
again that's an idea that the
Enlightenment believed in right and and
we've lost it we've lost that on both
left and right right I actually agree a
lot with that critique of the of the
critics of the Enlightenment now I want
to ask you about the right-wing critique
of the Enlightenment of which I count
myself sort
the member so that the right-wing
critique is that the enlightenment is a
bit of rewriting of history that
essentially the Enlightenment is living
off of the back of a judeo-christian
value system that is developed and and
purified over the course of several
thousand years and that by the time you
get to the Enlightenment well you don't
have is a break between reason and the
past what you actually have is the full
flowering of Reason in the context of a
particular culture which is why the
Enlightenment happens where it does at
the time that it does and the reason
that that critique matters is not just
historical so the reason the critique
matters is because the subsequent
history of the Enlightenment
particularly in places like France the
the Marxist views that I think can be
put as at least one half of the
Enlightenment that that that reason can
take you to some pretty dark places as
sort of the is sort of the critique that
you need some fundamental values to
build on top of using reason this is the
case for judeo-christian value systems
and that without those reason unmoored
can take you to some incredibly dark
places human beings are capable of
reasoning themselves to all sorts of
horrible conclusions including the
collectivism that you hate so so there's
a lot of time packed yeah there's a lot
of content there so so let's start first
with the fact that I don't believe Marx
is a man of the Enlightenment at all I
think he's the negation of the
Enlightenment and as Paulo's a tradition
of negating the environment if you think
about if you think about the
Enlightenment I think it ends with Amano
Alcott I think content is the first
anti-enlightenment think of his whole
project safe faith is the safe faith
from from reason and he undercuts it and
from that point on the whole German
Romantic in philosophy tradition is an
anti enlightenment anti Reason tradition
and that includes Marx and of course
Marx is a Hague alien in many respects
and Hegel I mean the last thing you'd
say about Hegel ease as a man of reason
he believes contradictions exist and
what's the whole issue of logic logic is
the negation of contradictions it's it's
the recognition that there are no
contradictions and you've got to find
what is what is true and what is not so
so hey girl rejects logic and ultimately
rejects reason completely and Marx is
just a continuation of that trend so I
take the whole love of philosophy from
busou and cons on as being anti
enlightenment and undercutting
enlightenment
therefore the the the development of
communism and fascism and all of those I
consider those anti-enlightenment
movements and anti Western movements I
think that is the remnant of the anti
Western there's always this tension
between the west and the anti Western
ideas that are there below the surface
now we will definitely disagree is that
I believe that that in a sense a
judeo-christian tradition is one of
those it's a it's a anti Western remnant
that is constantly trying to fight
against the fundamental ideas of the
Enlightenment and in in many respects I
think Marxism is much more connected to
the judeo-christian tradition than it is
to enlightenment values and we could
talk about why that is or why I think
that but let's let's just take the
Enlightenment for a second so I don't
think they Lightman's I mean the
alignments flawed so I don't consider
the like this completed and
enlightenment is the beginning of a
process actually think again that Iran
in many respects is an Enlightenment
figure and completes many of the many of
the ideas and many of the goals of the
Enlightenment but the Enlightenment is
basically a a rejection in many realms
of life not in all of them but many
wells of that of the joy of the
judeo-christian tradition now you're
right in a sense that it doesn't come
out of nowhere of course it doesn't
there's an evolution evolution starts
with Thomas Aquinas you know bringing
Aristotle into the Catholic Church and
in the Scholastic's taking reason and
logic seriously and in the Renaissance
it's covery of Greek art and and and in
Greek ideas and humanism and all of that
leads to what I think is the flowering
of all of that which is the
Enlightenment the idea of placing reason
above all else and and now they don't
have it completely tight right they
don't know yet what to do with morality
they don't know where to get morality so
they rely on a judeo-christian morality
because in a sense that's all they have
they none of those thinkers Locke all
the way to Hume including the founding
fathers none of them are regional
philosophical thinkers when it comes to
ethics the original philosophical things
when it comes to other areas certainly
political philosophy geniuses but when
it comes to ethics are not originally
there not original thinkers and
therefore they rely on the
judeo-christian tradition they're
uncomfortable with it as Thomas
Jefferson you know
creating a Jeffersonian Bible
illustrates right he cuts out the stuff
he doesn't like and he keeps only the
good stuff for what he considers the
good stuff they're uncomfortable with
that tradition but they don't know where
else to look for morale now we'll
150-200 you you know return of last
year's post and again I think a man is
an important philosophical figure that
kind of bridges that and she provides I
think now a philosophical foundation for
finding that morality that's consistent
with a political thinking it's
consistent with the idea of reason that
the Enlightenment is so is which is so
important in the Enlightenment and now
there's also immorality and now I think
fully we can we could put aside the
judeo-christian tradition and say no
that's that that's in a sense an
anti-western force and we don't need it
anymore now if you want me to connect
the Marxism to the judeo-christian
tradition I'm happy to do well minutes
were maneechan critique right I mean
Nietzsche essentially argues that
Christianity is the morality of the weak
against the strong and Marxism is
somewhat similar so that that's sort of
the Nietzsche it's more than that I
would say I'd say that the you know
Christian particularly Shannon you know
I want to emphasize cuz I don't want to
get into long discussion of Judaism
Christianity I think is more influential
I think I've caught it so dominant so
it's it's it's it's it's it's easy to
critique and I think Judaism is more
subtle and more difficult to gritty but
but Christianity emphasizes the wall of
self-sacrifice it emphasizes the idea of
the meek shall inherit the earth the the
idea that there's something suspicious
about wealth the idea that pursuing
yourself interest is bad and we could
talk about why American Christians have
a different view but but for the moment
that is the mall view I mean ultimately
there's a Jesus on a cross dying for
sins he didn't commit and that's a mall
ideal he is a superhero right that's
horrible in my view you don't die for
since you didn't commit I mean it's okay
to suffer sins you did commit but for
since you didn't commit that's the
biggest thing justice in in all of this
mythology is Jesus on a cross that's a
massive injustice he shouldn't be there
so but that's the symbol because it's a
symbol of sacrifice and that's the most
noble most virtuous most ethical thing
anybody could do now so what is he
sacrificing for a psycho saint god but
ultimately sacrificing for other people
he's sacrificing for the group he's
sacrificing to the collective now
what Marx does is it is a cool trick in
my view in
in a sense he substitutes the Paulette
Aryan for God and he says yes the
individual should sacrifice the
individual should live for others the
individual should be completely
altruistic he should be completely
selfless but since there is no God we're
not gonna do it for God I mean I don't
believe in that we're gonna do it for
this group called the polity Mian
now it's convenient that you know how do
we know what's good for a group right so
we don't know it's good for groups so we
have to have somebody call it a
philosopher-king call it a platonic
philosopher king who has to commune with
the spirit of the group in order to tell
us and that's why we need a dictator in
order for at least until we all change
on HS somehow and become one with the
polity and and you know in enjoying the
communist utopia but to me communism is
much more Christian in that sense than
it is enlightenment it's it's indeed a
rejection or aligning you cannot get to
communism through reason communism is an
indication of reason it's a negation of
fact that's a negation of human nature
so it's it's anything that's negation of
reality anything that gates human nature
is not based on reason reason I mean
people think of reason is logic just
it's playing logical games in your mind
and unfortunately that's Conte Khan
divorces reason from reality he says we
can't really know real reality so all we
can do is play my games well reason is
not that reason the fundamental reason
is identifying the world identifying
facts identifying truth identifying
reality and if something negates reality
then it negates reason all right so now
I want to ask you about the more
controversial aspects of Objectivism and
this is in the interpersonal realm so I
remember that Stephen Colbert did a skit
back when he was doing I think the Daily
Show with Jon Stewart with an
Objectivist kindergarten and the kids
were banned from sharing because sharing
was obviously terrible they weren't
allowed to share toys with each other
and it was sort of a funny riff but that
is the general kind of public perception
of what objectivism is that because
selfishness is bad that sharing toys
between children is bad we have to teach
them if to punish them for sharing
because selfishness is good now earlier
on you made the distinction between sort
of just being nice and being altruistic
and I want to push on that for a minute
because how do you make that distinction
meaning that Oh
of the nice things that we do on a daily
basis are things that mildly
inconvenience us like it does in
convenience you to open the door for
somebody that's not something that's
necessarily in my reasonable interest I
could just walk out the door where do
you make the distinction between what I
think most people consider altruism and
just being nice
well are you giving up a value that is
more important than what you're
providing right so I think goodwill
among people having a benevolent view of
other people and treating other people
with with with respect and kindness is a
value and if I'm not you know trying
rushing because my kid has to get to the
emergency room and I have to drive him
there and I'm rushing to save my kid's
life to hell with anybody trying to go
right of course right because that's
clearly my self-interest is to do that
and that is my primary focus if I'm
running to a meeting him on a little
late I might not stand there and open
the door for somebody but you know if
time is not that important at that point
then that goodwill is a higher value
than when I'm giving up right so to me
every human being his moral
responsibility is to work at a hierarchy
of values what is your most important
value and what other what where all the
other values fall in this hierarchy and
one of the ideas around this has never
give up a high value for Louisville now
we always do what constantly doing
trade-offs right so people say well you
go you know you go to the to the movies
and you don't you give up going to the
movies to stay with your kids
now you're sacrificing the movies really
no my kids are great a higher value
spending time with my kids there's a
higher value than going to the movies
so I spent time with my kids right so
there is a there's a value hacky
sacrifices when you give up something
higher for something lower I don't
sacrifice how are you how are you
measuring the value meaning that in
terms of immediate joy obviously that's
not true I mean if your kids barfing in
the in the bathroom a movie but but
again a media joy is not the standard
for every anything nobody nobody could
nobody really seriously when you think
about what is life mean think about the
instantaneous gratification I mean some
people do that's why they're drug
addicts and so on like but but that's
not a serious view of human life human
life is lived over the long run given
that I know that I
don't even get joy from the short-term
things because I know if I know I'm in a
sense sacrificing the future for for
getting a thrill right now I don't even
enjoy the thrill right now I mean you
made a critique I think and Dave Rubin
show you something about the woman at
the bar Yeah right if you're selfish
you're going for the woman to bar I'm
not attracted to the woman at the bar
because my whole view of sex my whole
view of my own life is hooked into what
is rational and what is long-term so the
woman at the bar doesn't provide me any
kind of yes I could get an instant
thrill out of that but the instant
thrill is not valuable to me and it's
only not valuable to me on the scale of
the kind of values I'd be giving up in
order to get that - we understand trade
offs and economics all the time well the
same thing is true in morality in here
if I have a principle and again we
derive principles from what is
successful to human life over the long
run what is rational and successful then
I'm never gonna be tempted to lie I'm
never gonna be tempted to cheat I'm
never gonna be tempted by cheap thrill
it just doesn't interest me because I'm
so focused on what is good for me in the
long run and that's the challenge that
morality places well he's not easy in
the sense that it's effortless morality
requires thinking
it requires engaging with your mind
engaging what's truly in your long-term
self-interest and actually doing it one
of the things that sort of fascinating
in Atlas Shrugged to take an example is
the passivity of people in terms of
their sexual relationships so there
there is one character who obviously is
very sexually needy and is is seen as
sort of a drain on one of the other
characters but Dagny kind of bounces
from through a series of men before she
ends up with John Galt and everybody
seems sort of okay with this right I
mean she she moves it she moves from man
to man and all the men are said well she
know that she's just pursuing her is
that in any way a realistic view of how
human beings interact or or she and is
there anything about her behavior in
Atlas Shrugged that is immoral in in
taking Hank Rearden away from his family
it's his wife who's seen a sort of no
need of hers in her but taking Hank
Rearden anchored and pursues her she
drops him and he's just fine with this
this is all fine that seems like a
pretty well but first I know I think
it's a I would flip it on you I would
say it's a it's a model for moral
behavior not only is it an emo it's a
model
behavior she is pursuing her values not
in a short-term thrill remember she's
not bouncing from man to man she sleeps
with three men all of them giants right
right now I have different inclinations
but all of them if I if I was a woman I
would want to sleep with right I mean
these are not just men that she picks up
at a bar of course he's a Giants of
morality of Industry of of integrity of
so many things and weirdin is an
interesting character in Atlas show
because he's the one character who
really evolved through the novel he
begins a novel with loaded up with his
guilt and loaded up with this duty to be
with his wife he doesn't love any and he
has no real honest relationship with and
he's duty-bound because he's been given
this morality of altruism his whole life
a if you marry somebody you just have to
stick with it be you know sexist
animalistic it's barbaric it's it's
so-so
you just have to do it because it's your
duty and just and so he has an unhealthy
relationship over here and he starting
to break out of that he's starting to
his mind is racing he's exposed to
another character now it was drug that
is making him think about this and then
he meets this woman who has blows him
away right again not a floozy at the
ball right now it's just something but a
giant at this amazing woman right and
and he's sexually attracted to a
sexually attracted to I would say in a
healthy way because he's attracted to
her value not just to the physical act
but to what it what she represents and
what she means and he pursues her and
ultimately has sex with him and if you
remember the scene after you have sex
with he condemns himself for having sex
with right because again he views it as
an animalistic
and it takes the whole book for him to
really realize that it's not sex is not
animalistic that pursuing his own
self-interest is not evil that that he
is a that it that his relationship with
the real evil relationship the real bad
relation was his wife and her family and
a brother all leeches on him and that he
needs to he needs to flee himself in
that relationship and actually not
pursue his what happens if Hank has a
kid right way in the the book is easy in
the sense that there are no children
anywhere yeah so what happens if Hank
and his wife have a kid
now it's not just a question of him
breaking up a marital Val which may be
burdensome to him but they're both
adults and now it's a question of
there's this other thing that is here
because we talk about hierarchy of
values this has been a hierarchy of
values that in the West has been
completely forgotten as the divorce
rates skyrocket and people make the
selfish decision to suggest that divorce
has no impact on children that it's had
a massive impact on children well but
but when we don't know and it's hard to
imagine right we don't know maybe
because it's hard to measure what is the
what is the impact on children of living
in a loveless marriage
what is an impact of children and living
in a marriage where they the two despise
each other which would be the case of of
Reardon and and and his wife I think
that's much more damaging so my view is
psychologically much more damaging than
getting a divorce is living in a
marriage that is horrible that is that
is awful that is making a pod where
people despise each other so I would say
you know if he had a child then I would
hope he would get custody because I
think his wife is a horrible evil you
know anyone being so I would want him to
raise the child and take them take them
to the valley and and live happily ever
after and yes it's not ideal the ideal
would be to marry somebody who you truly
love and you have a relationship over
many many decades and you raise children
with and and and everybody's but that
doesn't always happen sometimes you
marry somebody and you discover after
five years after 10 years you know you
don't like each other and even though
you've got children the the living
together is more damaging and more
dangerous for the kids and actually
getting it mean is that a convenient
answer that the social science seems to
suggest that the parents living apart
have I mean it does how it breaks apart
your child's world and is there a
gradation here I mean you're talking
about the extreme case of you have one
spouse who's in the book legitimately
evil and one who is of course there's
everything she might again and again you
would have to evaluate as a human being
you would have to value but here's the
question it's not you evaluating it's
you evaluating maybe meaning your own
evaluating not it's not because you're
saying that there is a objective
reasonable standard by which we could
assess whether somebody's behavior is
correct or not so it's not gonna
evaluate you right your responsibility
in your life is to is to make these
evaluations I'm gonna tell you Molly
what the standard for you value for what
the standard for you to make a decision
is and that is use reason you know be
honest think about all the facts taken
to eke out all the
all the evidence don't invade don't be
emotional about the decision that would
be how you make the somewhere where do
you your own decide where to condemn
somebody else's moral decision
meaning that you know I think I think
it's I think it's very difficult to
condemn somebody else's moral decision
in in many cases it's hard there's
certain things that aren't equivocal if
somebody is if somebody is clearly being
dishonest if somebody's clearly being a
leech off of other people if somebody is
driven by emotion and not using their
mind that to me is amol so I don't think
about morality in terms of did they get
a divorce or didn't they that they sleep
around or didn't they I think a morality
in terms of how did they come to the
decisions that they came to what is the
process and I look at the behavior and I
look at what led to that behavior so to
me it's it's how are they living and
what are the principles that are guiding
their life in to the extent that the
being dishonest the extent that they're
not being productive to the extent that
they are that they're negating reason or
being irrational to the extent that they
don't take pride in their own
achievement I consider all of those
things Amahl and the fundamental for
objectivism in terms of what is Amal is
evasion is is evading reality is evading
facts and so many people particularly
comes to divorce our children as things
like that there's certain facts that are
inconvenient I'm not going to think
about that that to me is the essence of
immorality well this is I think that the
fascinating distinction in my Oh matters
I think about this between why I am warm
on on Randian thought when it comes to
economics but not as more when it comes
to interpersonal relationships and the
reason is because when it comes to
economics there are guardrails to reason
the guardrail is I can want you to give
me as much money as I want you to give
me but if you're not willing to do that
then I have no say in the matter the
guardrails are the value of consent
right and the value of your
individualism but when it comes to
interpersonal relationships very often
particularly when children are involved
then you get into the realm of
externalities and I wonder how does
objective a spa deal with externalities
because my relationship with my wife has
a pretty significant externality that is
how we treat each other how we live
together in a house how that how that
deals with kids and that raises the the
economic question that I'm sure you're
asked very often how do you deal with
folks in a society who are not capable
of reason can't take care of themselves
the value of selfishness is of little as
little concert to folks for mentally ill
for example how do you deal with that as
a society where does selfishness come
into that well I mean let's think about
what extent alleys mean cuz they you
know I don't think about externalities
in interpersonal sense in which in which
Oh suddenly the way my wife and I
interact affects our children right and
it look I'd be married thirty my wife's
here so thirty six thirty six years
right so so I you have done this I've
got two boys so so you know I've done
all this and yes the way you interact is
is crucially important to the way you
raise kids and you have to take that
into accounting you have to think about
it and again when you think about having
kids this is what I think it's so
important not to have kids unless you're
ready to have kids and if you want to
have kids and unless you're willing to
make the commitment to what it takes to
have kids but once you have them you've
made a certain commitment to interacting
in a certain way to behaving in a
certain way to treating them and a
certain with a certain in a certain way
all of that you know is something you
take on when you have kids and you have
to like everything else in life you have
to reason it through you have to
rationally consider all the all the
elements all the impacts and then adjust
them but it's it's very hard to say that
couple is is being a model because of X
Y Z from the outside because you don't
have all the information morality
requires a lot of information to make
moral judgment about another person even
in moda
right we don't jump to the conclusion
there's a whole trial we look at the
evidence we figure it out and sometimes
it's self defense and it turns out that
killing somebody else is not an immoral
thing sometimes killing somebody else is
the model thing to do because self
defense is more now when it comes to
externalities in economics again the
different ways to think about this
usually the externalities that I get in
kid mentalism are they final ISM bit but
you're right there are externalities
about around let's say poor people my
view of externality is wrong poor people
is they're all positive or almost all
positive capitalism allows the poor to
rise up it provides them better jobs
that makes them more productive it in
every respect capitalism is a beneficial
and in that respect if you think about
people who can't help themselves if you
think about you know the mentally
who can't who can never get a
job or somebody who's really suffered a
debilitating disease or something like
that well
has made us so rich it's relatively easy
to take care of people like that the
systems that make it impossible to take
care of people like that a socialism
where everybody's dying and everybody's
starving all you know pre capitalist
society where people people basically
died if you if you couldn't take care of
yourself you died if your family do it
wasn't wealthy enough to take care of
you you died today most families can
take care of a sick kid most families
and again we live in a non capitalist
society today we live in mixed economy
we're a lot cooler than we should be you
know a health care system should be a
lot cheaper and a lot more efficient
than it should be if it was privatized
so with all of those caveats it's still
true that most people can take care of
because we're so wealthy in in relative
terms
so capitalism provides that wealth now
beyond that and we'll get to in five
militarism in a minute beyond that I
also think that charity can be a
wonderful thing again a you know having
a positive attitude towards other human
beings I don't want to I have no
interest in seeing other people suffer
valium and B say I value my clients in
my house why do I value plants because
it's a it's something alive there's
something beautiful and something
wonderful and something valuable to
human consciousness about something
being alive well if you value a plant
and we value our pets Wow
another human beings life is an amazing
value and unless I know something
horrible about this human being in which
case I don't help them but if they're
basically a good human being or if I
don't know anything about them and I and
I want to be benevolent then I'm gonna
help them I have no problem with charity
and help again as long as it doesn't
come at the expense of my kids my life
my ability to progress so once you've
taking care of yourself
just I've say nothing in objectivism
it's anti charity and indeed I meant
considered it a minor fortune on a major
virtue but a minor vote to be charitable
towards others so that's how and I think
at the end of the day those people get
taken care of a by family and B by
charitable institutions that provide
whatever you know the services and needs
that they get taken care of in terms of
a environmentalism I mean a solution to
external these externalities is another
way of talking about the problem of the
Commons and I like to talk about it in
terms in the comments because my you
Buttle to that is well let's get rid of
the car
right if you privatize everything it's
relatively easy right I know we know
that I can't put my garbage in your
backyard because there's private
property and for two thousand years
we've had common law that has said that
is not if we privatize the lakes and if
we tie privatize new rivers and we had
water rights and it was all clear about
what those rights implied and there was
a beginning of that in the nineteenth
century in the late 19th century with
the West and development of West this
beginning of development of a law that
related to water rights and things like
that all went away when the government
took it all over but imagine we lived in
a world will be privatized all that you
privatize fishing rights you privatize
the oceanfront and all of that and I
don't know necessarily how to do it but
that's something you need servos it's
something that economists and Foster's
of law need to figure out but if you did
that a lot of these issues Vic's
tonalities go away if you're spearing
cyanide and I'm and I'm breathing it and
it's it's clearly damaging me then I sue
you and once it's been established and
of course it's cyanide in the airs bad
for people it's fine for the legislature
to come in and ban cyanide from being
spewed into the air I you know but the
standard has to be human well-being and
it has to be proven and I prefer there
was proven in a court of law and then
the legislature steps in and generalizes
off of that versus today where the EPA
stud decides that a fraction of a
fraction of a fraction of some chemical
maybe one day we're not sure will cause
you some harm so therefore were banning
it by some arbitrary standard or by
political manipulation by you know we've
got the coal lobby and we've got the
environmentalist Lobby and we've got the
workers lobby and we've got 50 lobbies
all pulling in different directions and
in regulations to determine or laws the
determine protection of individual
rights which is I think the only role of
government are determined by you know
this pull these these poke peddlers
these these so-called special interest
groups they're really pressure groups
rather than by facts so I think all of
these have relatively easy answers I
mean realistically can can you privatize
the air I mean when you're talking about
pollution smog in Los Angeles for
example and the chain of causation is
not necessarily clear because everybody
is driving the car in the city of Los
Angeles and you have a major free-rider
problem how do you exactly determine who
exactly did this
and even if half people don't do it you
can't so so so the deal is with us
Angeles I think it's very easy if you
don't like smog in Los Angeles don't
live in Los Angeles we live in a big
country Wyoming is unbelievably pretty
and there's no smog in Wyoming don't
live in Los Angeles
the idea that I get to move to Los
Angeles right and say no too many people
are driving I should be able to vote to
stop them or to change the kind of cause
at the Drive or put filters on I mean
that's absurd this city is built and
cause this is the city there was it was
founded on the highway system on and
mass transportation through cause if you
don't like that if that offends you if
that causes you some health problems
move away or don't come to Los Angeles
right the sudden ways in which we can
privatize certain air rights right you
can you know if I have a home and then
you start flying airplanes above my home
and you're disturbing me there's certain
legal recourse that you can get for that
but if the airport was there first and
now I buy the home and now we complain
about the planes tough I mean I'm I I
agree in terms of the chain of in the
chain of timing but I mean are we
setting up a system where if in these
sort of John Stuart Mill I can wave my
fist until I hit you in the face now
we're saying to people that if they're
getting hit in the face they have to
keep receding from the person who's
waving they're waving they're handing me
say moves Montana I moved to Montana and
then it turns out I build myself a nice
area in Montana and everybody says you
know what's great Montana and all the
people from el they decide to descend on
Montana and pollute Montana the same way
if civilization requires us to drive
caused and that's a cost of civilization
I'll give an example of this in 19th
century the middle of the nineteenth
century London the air was full of such
I mean literally coal I mean you were
breathing black law I mean it was really
change the color of moths
it was evolutionarily yes it was bad for
you it was bad for human health in a way
that the smog in LA doesn't even come
close to how bad it was imagine if at
that point we had decided this is bad we
need to shut down every coal manufact
every coal plant in London has to be oh
oh in the UK has to be shut down because
this is causing so harm to some people
you basically killing those very
revolution and we all subsistence
farmers again you that is that is
irrational it makes no sense so if there
is a pollution that is being generated
by something that is just part of living
in a civil I
country like driving a car then it just
is and and you have to adjust your
lifestyle to it not expect everybody to
stop driving or to take civilization
backwards in order to satisfy the fact
that you might live to 89 and three
months instead of 89 and two and a half
months because you you know you inhaled
a little bit of smog so on a generalized
level what exactly do you think the role
of government is I think a lot of folks
confuse Randian thought with
libertarianism which is not quite the
same thing and then they confuse it on a
more general level with the NRIC ISM
which it certainly is not so what so
what exactly is the Randi and view the
the Objectivist view of what government
ought to be doing well so so let me
derive it in a sense right so if we
believe that egoism is is is is morality
is the purpose of life is to is to live
using your mind you know to flourish as
an individual human being you know it's
a ten your own happiness then what do we
need to do that we need to freedom to
think and to freedom the freedom to
think and to act and what is the enemy
of reason what is the enemy of ideas of
thoughts of entrepreneurial ideas but
any kind of idea what the enemy of that
is coercion the enemy of that is
authority from above the any of that is
anybody who can pull a gun out and say
no you can't do that right so the role
of the states the role of government is
to extract that force away so can we
leave us free to use our minds to pursue
our own life which is the whole idea of
individual rights or concept of
individual rights is the idea of a
freedom the freedom to act in pursuit of
your own rational values
that's what individual rights are so the
only role of governments to protect
those individual rights in other words
to protect our freedom of action so it's
to exclude coercion from society's the
catch the crooks the criminals the
terrorists the invaders so it's a police
force it's a military and it's a
judiciary so we don't go out and duel in
the middle of the street so we have a
mechanism by which an objective
mechanism by which to arbitrate disputes
where non anarchist I believe government
is a necessary good and it's it's it's
necessary capitalism you know some
people out there call themselves a novel
capitalism I think that's a
contradiction in terms you cannot have
capitalism if you have anarchy
capitalism requires the rule of law it
requires contracts and it requires
government enforce all of that but it's
only job is that it's the protection of
individual rights it's a protection of
our freedoms so what's the role of
social institution so Rand is is very
big obviously on individualism
individual rights individual will the
ability to come up with a rational
system by which to live but where is man
as communal being so one of one of the
the acknowledgments that that I think
must be made to Marx is that he does
recognize that man does have a side of
him that wants to be part of a society
and part of a community he then takes
that to the ultimate extreme in the
exact wrong way obviously yes but what
is the balance between the need to be
part of a community and the sort of
individualism that's inherent in Randy
and thought of course Rand acknowledges
that completely and she says I mean
they're passages where she says you know
individualism just means living on a
desert island because it's signing your
self-interest to live into there's an
item other human beings are an immense
value to you whether phone economic
perspective because of the division of
labor the ability to trade and the
ability to specialize which is massively
beneficial you don't want to be a
Robinson Caruso you don't want to have
to do everything you want to be able to
specialize in pursue the thing that you
love and a good at rather than having to
do everything so there's a massive
economic benefit to living in a social
context but there's a spiritual benefit
to friendship love the benefit of having
other people to interact with to talk to
to engage in so to go to the movies with
listen to music with all of that is a
massive spiritual benefit that other
people provide to you so it's your
self-interest as an individualist to
pursue people who are true values to you
whether in terms of economic
relationships or whether in terms of
social relationships a friendship to her
is is is that the pinnacle of kind of
human relation but that is romantic love
is a love relationship but friendship is
incredibly value in a sense more
valuable than family excluding kids who
you chose to have but you don't choose
your rest of your family friends friends
you choose that's why friendship is so
important it's so valuable and it's and
you want to get that that you know that
kind of response from friendship that
enhances you and enhances the other
person and you're both
win-win relationship I always say you
know people think of Rand as this again
individualism means being on a desert
island but but wait is really about in
in life maximizing the win-win
relationships you have in your life
maximizing the the number of
relationships in which the traded
principle applies we're both a winning
and that's true in the economic sphere
again and in the spiritual sphere it's
it both are the same so it's just
something you mentioned kids sharing you
know I'll just say you know I I think I
don't like the idea of kids sharing in
in the sense that a stranger kid comes
up and I want to share your truck and
like who's this kid I don't know this
kid right I I would encourage my kids to
trade now if they're friends then of
course you shape but you don't share
with strangers we as adult don't share
with strangers right and kids shouldn't
be expected to show the trait who shares
with traders with strangers socialistic
communists share with strangers that's
the idea but as it is as individuals we
share with people we have a common bond
with with our friends with a family with
people we have respect and love for and
I think we should reflect that on our
kids as well so I don't encourage my
kids in the playground with strangers to
share with anybody I would encourage
them to say well what toy do you have
right let's we can trade we can play
together we can find a way to benefit
from one another rather than I want to
give them my tory well you know what
happened to property rights when you
become a kid it all goes out the window
or their own values it all goes out the
window but there's an enormous value in
in human relationships and there's a you
know most value in friendships in social
get-togethers and in doing things
together this the individualism doesn't
is not antisocial it's anti collectivism
it's anti putting the group above the
individual it's anti making the group
the fundamental whether for ethics like
Adam Smith says whatever's good for
society right that's not the standard
the standard is what is good for good
individuals what is good for virtuous
individuals that the kind of social
system that objectives and views is
positive is that social system way
virtuous individuals model individuals
thrive so I don't really care about
immoral individuals so when it comes to
teaching children I mean you mentioned
kids before how would you teach
objectivism to kids
is obviously the emphasis is on reason
kids are not able to reason for a goodly
period of time I have a five year old
and a three year old neither is I would
say very reasonable in their pursuits so
how do you teach a morality that has
written reason or is it basically that
you established the rules of the road
for them and then later you explain to
them why those rules more reasonable
well I think it's it's worth while
explaining throughout with the
understanding that they're not gonna get
it for a long time right
but it's always good to give
explanations because it's always good
for them to know that you are using
reason and there's a reason for why you
are banning certain things so I wouldn't
even tell a two-year-old don't go into
the street because and here's why it
would hurt you you'll be you know damage
can happen bad stuff can happen so it's
always good to give an explanation
recognizing that they won't have the
full context for the explanation and so
they're much older I think the main way
you teach morality to children is by
example is by modeling it it's by being
rational in your own life it's right how
you treat other people how you engage in
relationships with other people and then
over time explaining these things and
that the worst thing in the world is to
become preachy and to be and to also
treat morality the objectives morality
as if it's a is if it's a it's a set of
Commandments you see in objective as a
morality has to be understood otherwise
it's all morality it has to be accepted
through reason otherwise it's no value
so you want the child ultimately to
understand the virtues and values not
just to accept them on blind on faith
right to understand why they're in this
their own self-interest to be virtuous
why virtue is consistent with
self-interest right the Objectivist
virtues not again conventional morality
the votes is a conventional morality and
virtues of Objectivism are not the same
in many respects you know
something in cases diametrically
opposite but even when talk about
honesty I think the focus is very
different when we talk about honesty and
objectivism an honesty in the in the
kind of conventional cultural okay so
let's take that example so where were
they because you and I agree I think a
lot on values and we're coming from very
different points of view and that
obviously makes me think okay so is
selfishness properly understood just
code for morality that we all sort of
basically get and that morality doesn't
spring from nowhere right that gets made
my original point but with that said
we're
do you think the distinctions lie
between conventional morality and an
Objectivist morality and I don't really
mean on philosophical level let's take
some practical examples where you think
there's a difference well first let me
say I don't think most people a model
from an Objectivist perspective I don't
think they act Molly so yes they might
not lie but I don't think that's enough
I think to be fully Maul you have to
understand why you're not lying right
you have to understand what what the
cause and you have to understand that
it's in your self-interest I think
unless you're acting in your
self-interest you're not being fully
Maul um
second I think that value requires you
to actually think I mean really think
about what you're doing and why you're
doing it and analyze it and not just
when it comes to my career choice which
everybody accepts but in every aspect of
it I've actually figure up is this the
right thing to do and by what standard
is is annoyed determine what is right
that's what morality of the Objectivist
morality requires and objectivism
doesn't ever use it has a methodology it
has universal rules but you have to
follow us in methodology in order to
attain them and much of the universal
rules or by methodology said let's take
honesty for objectivism the most
important part about honesty is a
commitment to facts a commitment to
reality and therefore the person that it
is most important for you to be honest
with to be moral is yourself so lying
only comes in later first you have to a
commitment to rationality means a
commitment to facts a commitment to
reality commitment to what's true and
that means a commitment to my own mind a
commitment to my own judgment it means a
commitment to me not evading and not
pretending you're not using my emotions
to guide me but a commitment to my own
reason that's what honesty to me means
and yes by extension that means I
shouldn't fake to other people because
if I are not faking to myself then I
shouldn't fake to other people and
getting a value on the basis of
something fake is undercutting my own
reason my own productiveness my own self
esteem it undercuts Who I am as a human
being so I don't lie to other people
because it's bad for me right because
it's not good for my long-term success
as being a human being I mean I could go
on you know line doesn't work lying is
right sis stupid strategy right it's
stupid self-interested strategy but the
fundamentalist don't lie to yourself the
fundamental is facts reality evidence
that's what the virtue of honesty means
in objectivism and the orientation in
conventional morality is always towards
the other conventional morality doesn't
talk about how you should treat yourself
conventional morality for the most part
talks about how you should treat other
people in objectivism how you should
treat other people is important but it
it comes as a consequence of how you
should treat yourself it comes as a
consequence of what it means to pursue
your own your own you own life and your
own happiness and the virtue that
captures how you should treat other
people in in objectivism is put is the
virtue of justice you should treat
people in a just way and what is justice
mean in this context it means how they
deserve to be treated and what does that
mean it means you know how malo they are
what kind of value do they represent to
you and what kind of value are they do
they represent in the world out there so
is that a mystery of conventional
morality meaning I mean going all the
way back to the the golden rule there's
the basic notion that you shouldn't
treat others the way you wouldn't want
to be treated yourself which i guess is
sort of an aspect of selfishness but yes
but it's it's all about other people it
starts with other people you how should
I treat other people I say forget about
other people for a minute right
well well he's about it you should treat
yourself and and how you treat other
people is an aspect of how you treat
yourself you treat yourself now in
Hebrew in law and nearly melee right
right which is which is a heckuva yeah
yes he said the Father
yes you start with yourself you start
with what is good for me and then from
that comes how you should treat other
people what that the Golden Rule used to
do to other people the way you want to
be treated yourself which is the
Christian goal the Jewish gold rule is a
negative right food which i think is
healthier yeah Christian I have my
biases yes philosophically I think it's
healthier but it certainly is the same
this idea that you know why why be just
the reason to be just is because you
want to surround yourself with people
who are adding value to your life
because that'll make your life better
and you want to distance yourself from
people
who hurts your values so again it's
selfish justice is a selfish value I
don't want people are gonna hurt me I
want them to keep them away so treating
them the way they deserve so the
framework is completely around what is
good for me as a rational human being
over the long run you know over my
entire life and and thinking about that
and once you think about that then
there's no conflict between the short
run then in the long run so you know
today I don't think about lying on that
line because right it's it's I've I've
looked around the world I've seen it I
read it and I read but I didn't take it
just on faith then looked around and say
yeah I can see what happens to Liars
like I could see what it what it does
and I know what it does to my own mind
the other thing the lion does is I
believe them the human mind is an
integrating machine we want to see
connections between everything we want
to we want to integrate everything every
every part of what knowledge is is
really the integration of facts and when
you put lies into your mind when you put
falsehood it's your mind and when you
like to other people in a sense you're
putting a falsehood into your mind your
minds gonna integrate it and it's gonna
mess up your own ability to think and be
rational and in there's a term in
computers garbage in garbage out the
last thing you want is to put garbage
into that this amazing thing that we
have this amazing mind that we have
right because it'll screw up your
ability to be rational and therefore to
pursue your own happiness and to achieve
your own happiness so it's it's doing
life facts reality reason are too
important to me to deceive myself or
anybody else okay so in one second I'm
gonna ask you our final question I want
to ask you how objectivism these these
very deep and interesting ideas map onto
contemporary American politics so from
the sublime to the ridiculous but first
if you want to hear your own Brookes
answer you have to be a daily water
subscriber to subscribe head on over to
daily we're calm click subscribe you can
hear the end of our conversation there
Yaron thank you so much for time really
sure thank you for stopping to say a lot
of fun
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
directed by Mathis Glover and produced
by Jonathan hey executive producer
Jeremy borin associate producer Colton
Haas our guests are booked by Kaitlyn
Manor post-production is supervised by
Alex singhara editing by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike her Amina hair
and makeup is by Jesuit alvera title
graphics by Cynthia Angulo the Ben
Shapiro show Sunday special is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20